because you remember I said right at the
start of this lesson that there are two
kind or proportion or two kinds of
variation one where the two quantities
get bigger together and one where one
getting bigger makes the other smaller
so my comparison was money versus Donuts
they both got together and then delights
versus people I you know as as one gets
bigger the number of people the amount
of donor I could eat it's more so here
is an example of what we're talking
about and when you think about it it
makes sense temperature is inversely
proportional those are really important
words to highlight as you write this
down so underline them will actually get
a highlighter out temperature is
inversely proportional to altitude now
that makes sense right altitude is how
far you are above sea level as you go
further and further away the earth is
warm right so the closer you are to the
earth the warmer you are you get further
and further away your altitude increases
it gets cooler until eventually you know
you're in space right at 600 meters
above sea level they just give us this
as an example the temperature is 8
degrees Celsius so we're going to do
three things with this number one we're
going to form an equation just like we
did before we're going to test out like
how do we use that equation to find out
a value and then lastly we're going to
graph it here's where it really gets
interesting okay so let's begin just by
forming the equation first so I guess
we'll call this part a for me equation
okay now excuse me you remember before
right we formed an equation for the
variation between distance and time when
one got bigger the other one got bigger
to here it's exactly the reverse so I'm
going to say temperature equals but
instead of having some number multiplied
by your other quantity some other
multiplied by time it's going to be some
number I don't know what it is so I'm
just going to give it a label that's
what we do it algebra right I'm not
going to multiply by altitude because
the relationship is in the opposite
direction
what's the opposite
it operation to multiplication is
division right so where is direct
proportion direct equals multiplication
here for indirect or inverse
I got a do division which is the
opposite right so I'm going to divide by
a you might like to just put down over
here you know what T is its temperature
you know what a is its altitude this K
here is some number I don't know yet so
since I don't know what it is I just
give it a label and I'll come back to it
it doesn't take me long to come back to
it in fact now that I've written an
equation I formed the equation for this
weird different relationship I can use
the numbers given to us you the question
to find out what that unload number is
right
the temperature is 8 when the altitude
is 600 do you see what I've done I've
taken the information the question and
I've put it into the appropriate spots
which is caught will we do this room
that equation started s we've
substituted right instead of T average I
deserved that I said started this
instead of T over an 8 I've substituted
8 instead of a I've written 600
unsubstituted
ok now I guess I can simplify oh I I
thought if I care what do I do to both
sides look carefully I will get I will
multiply by 600 right is my time tables
are still serving me well I'm pretty
sure that's what K will be okay does
that make sense so therefore I can say
the temperature will be 4800 divided by
your altitude okay so now if you go your
altitude or you know your temperature
you can find out the other quantity for
instance what would the temperature be
you were a thousand meters above sea
level not a what's it called not 600
meters it's going to be four thousand
eight hundred divided by thousand which
is four point eight degrees so you can
see it's getting colder as you get
higher does that make sense